next a new study confirms something we
already know america loves road trips oh
please yes
again this is another story i can get
really behind people reports a new
survey of 2 000 drivers found 76 percent
of them would pick driving over flying
if they knew the drive would be
enjoyable and 74 said the journey is
more important than the destination and
78 said that they found hidden gems
along the way that they would have never
found otherwise and more than half said
that the perfect road trip buddy is
their partner that's fortunate
um and a lot of people also in this uh
survey said that a spontaneous road trip
can be equally if not more enjoyable
than a planned road trip ross thoughts
well okay i want to be very clear i find
driving in traffic to be outrageous like
i get like stressed out about it that
being said i love to dilly and i love to
dally and so if we could go on a road
trip and just take our time and explore
sign me up other thing i love about road
trips i thought a lot about this snacks
can we talk about road trip snacks
beef jerky jerky
give me a big gulp which i know means
we're going to stop a few times but i
don't care i want that big gulp
i actually have some pictures of how
enthusiastic i am about road trips so
i'm an rv enthusiast and this is me when
i'm 19 years old starting my rv journey
um yep that's me and my dog templeton um
he's long gone
and that's nan uh doing the windshield
because you know you hit a lot of bugs
along the way
and um anyone who can do rving uh i
highly suggest like a classy license
like a tioga style there's two beds a
little table
you don't have to have a special
driver's license for it and you just
take a map and flip coins at
intersections should we go right or left
i don't know flip the coin
it's the greatest thing on earth to do
and i couldn't recommend it more yeah
you know welly and i i actually pitched
to him because my fantasies to go like a
winnebago through like montana and so i
said what do you think for the honeymoon
and we are going to go to mexico
[Laughter]
well something for everybody we'll be
right back
[Music]